a polymath or homo Universalis is
somebody who excels in multiple
different disciplines who's able to
contribute meaningful work across
multiple different fields so the
prototypical example of the polymath is
Leonardo da Vinci the painter the writer
the scientist the inventor but during
his time the Renaissance period and
throughout history it was actually much
more common for people to be polymath of
this ilk Renaissance men and women
aristocrat they would spend their
evenings writing painting listening to
music playing instruments doing
experiments reading learning about
science writing theories it's something
that we just don't do anymore so what
happens to the polymaths where did they
all go there's actually a lot of reasons
for this first of all those people were
aristocrats like I said these were very
wealthy very fortunate individuals who
didn't have to work didn't have to graft
they had plenty of free time in order to
pursue these finer things in life and
they're probably pretty bored so what
else are you gonna do when you don't
have TV when you don't have a Nintendo
switch in order to distract you most
last time you came in from a very busy
day at work and decided you wanted to
learn about quantum physics and then
build a robot at the same time another
reason for this was the back then during
that period each field had progressed
not as far as it has today these days in
order to make a significant contribution
to even an incredibly niche field let's
say gaze direction in primates you'd
needs to do years of study you need to
pursue a PhD and probably knew tons of
your own research and even then you'd
only know about that very specific
aspect of biology there's just too much
to know pointers you need all that study
you need all that background that takes
so long in order to learn enough to
progress that you need to specialize in
order to make any kind of significant
contribution or at least that's the
theory but I'm here to argue that we're
going through a Renaissance of
Renaissance men and women I'm here to
argue that this is the second coming of
the polymath the digital polymath first
of all we now have access to more
information online than ever before we
now live in a time when anyone can study
anything without leaving their house and
that
course creates huge potential for
learning multiple different fields
multiple different topics at the same
time we're reaching a point where you
actually don't need to become a master
of your subject in order to contribute
once again and the example I'd like to
talk about is game development and indie
games in particular so when games first
came about they ran on spectrums they
ran on Tatem Einsteins and bbc's and
amstrad's they're very simple they had
small processing power anyone could make
a hit game in their attic in their mom's
basement because they didn't need a huge
team they only had about two megabytes
to work with on a cassette tapes they
couldn't create these hugely detailed
worlds they couldn't record music so
they didn't need to score their own
soundtracks they didn't need to find
people to record the voiceovers famous
actors and the graphics powers just
weren't there
most sprites were a couple of pixels at
most so it didn't take long for anyone
to create a game and then compete with
the best of the best so we'd only take a
couple of people to make a game I
arkanoid and have a massive hit on their
hands then games got grander in scope
they got more ambitious we've got things
like Shenmue a fantastic game that's
just been re-released which had an
orchestral soundtrack and such a
detailed world that you could control
Rhea and his house and go into every
single individual draw pick out each
item and move it around in 3d
how was one person supposed to compete
with that and so games developers became
large teams games cost thousands or
millions of dollars to create and it
wasn't possible anymore for one person
to compete with a huge corporation but
then it changed again because tools like
unity and like Unreal Engine give we
indie developers the tools we need to
create something far more powerful
without having to build it from scratch
so if you stole unity on your PC and
start developing with that for instance
you can use that physics engine so that
means it calculates things like gravity
the way things bounce the way things
move you can go on asset store you can
download 3d models you can get 3d models
for free online you can import those
into your game so you can have a hugely
detailed tree in seconds without having
to create it yourself so we have
crowdsourcing we have far more powerful
tools and we have this open source
attitude that allows us to work together
and to build off of what other people
have created and the same goes for ton
of other industries
have incredibly powerful cameras right
in our pockets we have access to
high-tech editing software we can create
things that we never could have before
we can use Fiverr in order to outsource
the bits we can't do ourselves and we
can build on the work and the research
of other people and discuss it on forums
in order to fill in the blanks and our
own knowledge so using the Internet as a
resource for information and at the same
time a collaborative tool is possible
for an individual to now do what would
have once taken a huge team and so once
again we're seeing a resurgence of the
polymath people who were skilled in
multiple disciplines genius billionaire
playboy philanthropist video editors you
can also play music you can also write
you can also sing you also know a ton
about quantum physics and are building
projects in their basements this is now
a thing again and thanks to the gig
economy which I've talked about before
and which I'm writing a book on right at
the moment it's now possible to make a
living this way as well from delving
into all kinds of different skills I
actually think that the impetus is on us
now to educate ourselves and to build
our own skill sets and our own abilities
and actually I think it's really
important that you do this salaries are
no longer increasing at the rate of
inflation and so the only way you can
stand out and get ahead of the pack is
to add letters after your name to gain
new skills new experiences to add to
your portfolio to head out there and to
train yourself if your company isn't
offering you those training
opportunities and you should definitely
take them if it is well then you need to
go out there and you need to find them
yourself this is especially true for
people like me who are self-employed but
I also think it's true for anyone else
there's no reason that you can't at the
weekends volunteer somewhere we're going
to get invaluable experience there's no
reason why you can't do an online course
there's going to give you extra skills
and make you more employable at the same
time creativity as I've talked about on
this channel many times before is
essentially defined as connecting
disparate ideas there's no such thing as
an original idea there's just an
original permutation of existing ideas
so the more different topics you
understand the greater you're going to
be at bringing those different ideas
together looking at them from different
angles and different contexts and coming
up with new ideas and it's creative work
make no mistake that's going to survive
when machine learning and automation
begin to take our jobs because whilst
an automated program can handle customer
service whilst it can do data entry it
can only do basic programming no real
problem-solving and it can't do creative
work it also doesn't have empathy so
think about the skills you need to
develop in order to survive and thrive
in the coming economy in the fourth
Industrial Revolution as some people are
calling it and of course here at the
bi-linear we're interested in doing
whatever you can in order to improve
yourself whether that means getting
smarter stronger faster more creative in
order to live the life that you want and
have more freedom and excitement and one
of the best ways to go about this is by
learning more things so many people are
focused on boosting their memory
boosting that focus but if you can learn
more skills then you gain exponential
new capabilities imagine being able to
open a lock because you know how to pick
that lock imagine being able to talk at
any language when you're abroad and
impress the people you're with imagine
being able to create entirely new things
or learning more about the human body in
order to train in a better way imagine
learning martial arts using all of the
tools and resources on the web in order
to do this and I think that we are
seeing this more and more I think more
people are better educated and have more
knowledge than they did not that long
ago thanks to the Internet even if you
want actively pursuing that extra
information just being on YouTube and
watching videos like this one watching
TED Talks and things is giving you a
greater understanding and when you watch
videos on games and on videos when you
watch someone like Mark Brown or when
you watch someone like the nerd writer
or someone like Captain midnite you
realize these people are talking about
nerdy stuff you know computer games and
comics and films in a way that shows a
much greater understanding of the
artistry that goes into it and the
design we're appreciating things on a
much higher level
thanks to this open forum where we can
discuss them it's a hugely exciting time
to be alive I've talked about it before
we're always down on humanity and the
direction we're taking but actually
we're also making huge strides and the
internet offers such incredible
potential if we all become digital
polymaths imagine what we could
accomplish together
so if you want to heed this advice and
you want to become the digital polymath
what can you do to start making it
happen well you're starting off well by
watching videos on YouTube there's tons
of information that's completely freely
available here and a quick tip is to put
it on two times speed I do that a lot
and that way you can absorb more
information more quickly at the same
time you can do the same trick over
audible or with podcasts and podcasts
and things like audible are also really
useful for multitasking they allow you
to learn whilst you're doing something
else so we don't have that much time in
the day but if you make a commute to
work if you're cooking if you're working
out then there's nothing to stop you're
putting on a podcast or listening to a
YouTube presentation or listening to a
audiobook as you do that in order to
learn as you go at the same time of
course there are tons of resources for
people who want to learn more about
specific skills or want to gain
qualifications these days you can get a
personal training qualification online
the exact same one that you get in
person you can get accounting
qualifications online business
qualifications coaching whatever you're
interested in you can get really decent
qualifications then there are the much
shorter courses the things that are
either free or paid things like Udacity
can give you these or Skillshare there's
tons of them I'm helping Android
Authority work on some programming
courses at their DG IT Academy all these
options give you ways that you can learn
online set aside some time and consider
it in just the same way that you
consider your workouts at the gym it's a
form of self-improvement it is a kind of
workout so dedicate the same time to it
give yourself an hour a week half an
hour a week whatever you can afford to
learning Google of course is also an
incredibly valuable resource also Google
Scholar and so is knowing how to phrase
questions so that Google would give you
the correct answer there is a skill to
googling and there's a skill to asking
the right questions in general once you
find the website you're looking for or
you find the book that you want to read
being able to read quickly is also
really important so I recommend brushing
up on your speed reading techniques
sooo I'd like to do a video entirely on
speed reading in future but for now a
couple of tips the first is in order is
that you're going in for the information
you want read the blurb read some
reviews and then head into that book
looking for that thing and ignoring
what's not useful another tip is not to
sound out the words in your head but
instead to just glaze your eyes over it
and trying to desorb the meaning look at
the words don't necessarily sound them
out I have two ways of reading I used to
think I was the slowest reader in the
world because I'd take a book and I'd
like sound it out in my head the way my
mum used to do when she read to me I put
on the voices and everything I'd be like
where who goes there said Gandalf
smiling wryly
and then I'd obviously take a long time
to read and I still read like that when
I'm reading a novel that I really enjoy
but when I'm reading a textbook or a a
book like nudge or like deep work
something like that then I read in a
different way I blaze my eyes across it
I pick out the meaning and I stop and I
read more deeply at the areas that I'm
most interested in you can then also use
accelerated learning techniques in order
to make sure that you're picking up that
information more quickly so one of the
big problems when you're doing I just
described skimming through information
is that we can end up glazing over it
and not really engaging with it a
solution to this problem is to use the
Fineman technique named for richard
fineman
and this basically provides a framework
or structure for making sure that you
really understand what it is that you've
been reading and it's based around the
idea of teaching someone else in the
most simple way possible so after you've
read the book or the text or whatever
your job is to try and explain what you
just read in simple terms to someone
else ideally using things like metaphors
and analogies if you can't do that then
you've found the gap in your knowledge
and that's what you then need to go and
to learn more about as you can see then
learning topics and becoming a polymath
obviously isn't about just being able to
rote repeat numbers and the fact it's
about engaging with that information and
this not only helps us to better
understand it and actually employ it but
it also helps us to become better at
retaining that information and storing
it and a great article by Scott H Young
explains how one of the most important
factors is how you connect the
information that you learn with other
information that's how we cement it
because it's how we see its context and
it's how we see its value to us so don't
just read don't just skim though
just listen but actually think about how
it relates to other things you know
create metaphors and one of my favorite
tips I'll leave the link to that article
and description down below by the way
one of my favorite tips is to write
about what it is you want to learn
because this not only forces you to
repeat what you've learned but it also
causes you to understand it and to
regurgitate it and to put it into
context in a way that makes it make
sense I'm a writer by trade I write
10,000 words a day as a minimum most of
the time and so I've learned all kinds
of weird stuff some of it really useful
it's how I've learned a lot of my
programming some of it really not useful
every now and then there's something I
thought wasn't useful will come in handy
Dutch's when I managed to open up a door
that we were locked out off because I'd
written articles on lock picking and
such as when I was able to fix the
cistern in the bathroom because I'd
written an article about that
so there's value in every kind of
information by the way there's an extra
little tip what's similarly really
important when it comes to giving
context to what you're learning and
actually applying it is to have some
kind of goal in mind or some kind of
target this is what I've talked about in
the past when I've talked about learning
to program but don't just try and learn
to program don't to say I'm gonna learn
Java try and learn to make something
that's actually useful or interesting to
you so try make a calculator or try make
a game or try and make anything doing
this gives you much more focused it
means you're not learning a huge
abstract topic but you can follow steps
in order to get to an end destination
and of course you can then build on that
project or make something more creative
or more challenging and thereby learn
more information and keep growing your
knowledge in fact most programmers would
tell you they don't know every single
statement or command in any given
language they just know the ones they
need to get the thing done the same goes
for any other subjects if you want to
learn quantum physics if you want to
learn electronic engineering if you want
to learn martial arts then know what you
want to achieve and work towards that
goal if you want to learn a language say
obviously this is easier with subjects
that allow you to build something but at
the same time you can do the same thing
by setting yourself some kind of more
abstract goals such as being able to
converse with someone who knows about
that subject or being able to understand
a specific theory or being able to talk
that language well enough to survive an
interview is Tim Ferriss did in one of
his episodes
this is the exact tip that is shared in
Josh Kaufman's excellent book the first
20 hours he talks about a minimum target
performance level and this is basically
the set level you're trying to achieve
rather than just trying to know
everything know what you want to do and
as a polymath that's really useful
because you can know what you need from
each disparate subject in order to
achieve the thing that you're trying to
achieve by bringing together those
different skill sets in the unique way
that makes us highly valuable as
professionals in this new economy Tim
Ferriss also has his own approach to
accelerated learning by the way he calls
his the dis method and this basically
breaks down learning into different
steps that includes dissecting it
includes interviewing sequencing and
this basically means that you're not
just going to learn something following
the normal steps that you find in the
textbooks but think about what the best
order to learn is and he often talks
about starting from the endpoint so in
the case of learn to play chess he might
talk about looking at the finishing
position on the board and then working
backwards or he might talk about
learning the most difficult move in a
dance and then working backwards to
learn the more basic footing and this
basically again gives context to what
you're doing gives it more meaning makes
it more interesting emotion is really
important when you learn anything
because emotion is what makes us learn
when we find something to be seemingly
important to us even if it shouldn't be
whether it's entertaining whether it's
funny whether it's something we think we
can use to work towards our goals then
our brain releases hormones BDNF
dopamine etc that makes us focused and
that makes us more likely to form
permanent neural connections when we're
not engaged because it's so abstracted
it's hard to relate to our own lives or
just draw information then we just
forget and this is also why it's a
really good idea to use different
mediums when you're learning this is
again where the Internet can come in so
handy because you can watch videos you
can listen to music you can listen to
podcasts you can talk with people over
Skype and all these different formats
help you to cement that information more
clearly because it's saved in multiple
different modalities own guys of course
there is merit in doing whatever you can
to improve your health to get better
sleep to exercise and thereby encourage
brain plasticity you can also use
certain nootropics very carefully I
recommend the natural ones in order to
enhance
your plasticity and I did a whole video
on brain plasticity that I highly
recommend you check out as well the
really great thing is that brain
plasticity is a kind of virtuous cycle
once you start learning more your brain
becomes more plastic and this makes it
easier to learn more this is why
children's brains are so plastic I
believe not only because they go through
some kind of sensitive period in their
biology due to their natural development
but because everything that they do is
new from walking to listening to looking
and thereby their brain is awash with
hormones because they're constantly
amazed they're constantly in awe and
this makes their brains more plastic on
one last related tip you can also
achieve something similar by subjecting
yourself to more experiences by
traveling by having those moments of or
where you see incredible views and this
will likewise help you to increase your
plasticity and your ability to learn a
lot of people who are really focused on
self improvement and learning they make
what I believe is a big mistake
they focus on just doing those things
they cut out all the fun stuff their
relationships watching TV going out
drinking I actually believe that having
all these pillars in your life not only
makes you happier but it gives you all
those experiences that enriches your
brain and makes you better able to learn
then better able to perform of course
there will be some rote learning of dry
facts that's unavoidable and pretty much
any subject so here you can start using
memory master techniques I did a whole
video on this over on my video on
thinking like Sherlock Holmes I'll leave
the link in the description down below
recommend you check that out I'm going
to do more on memory in the future but
it's something I'd like to talk about
for now is using Anki flashcards so Anki
is a piece of software that helps you to
learn by looking at flashcards and then
testing your knowledge and it's supposed
to make you more likely to learn these
subjects that you're trying to learn
then competing software or competing
methods the reason for this is that it
applies to methods that have been
demonstrated in studies to be effective
the first is active recall basically
being asked questions being tested on
something is superior to just listening
to it and learning it in a passive way
this is why regurgitating and teaching
so useful it's why writing about it is
so useful but just remembering and
regurgitating out information back as we
did at school is also useful because
when we access information we're
practicing accessing it making it more
available and increasing those newer
connections at the same time Anke
flashcards use something called space -
learning space learning basically means
that you're asking yourself questions
you're rehearsing but then you're taking
a scheduled break at the optimum amount
of time and this has been shown in
studies to also increase our likelihood
of memorizing something the explanation
given for why this works is that it
allows the information to move from
short-term memory to long-term memory so
that we're then accessing it from there
again if you watched my video on working
memory and of course I recommend that
you do then you'll know that short-term
memory might not necessarily be a
storage container as people used to
think but rather it might just be
activation in our brain as in what seems
to be in a working memory is just the
neural connections that are activated or
that are potentiated it's when we
visualize something in our minds eye I
don't know what relation this would have
to space learning or why it works but I
suppose letting the neurons go cold and
then reactivating them might make them
more likely to form a long-term
connection but whatever I don't know why
this works but it does work and studies
demonstrate that it works and the other
great thing about Anki flashcards is
there's a huge community and you can
find stacks that other people have made
so if you want to learn about physiology
muscles of the leg a particular
programming language geography in a
particular area you'll be able to find
the flashcards that other people have
created online and download them and use
them for free so you can test yourself
wherever you are it's a really great
resource and it's a fantastic example of
using the Internet in order to learn
faster using not only the Internet as a
resource of information but using it as
a way to crowdsource all that
information and utilize the power of the
masses the groupthink there are many
more examples of accelerated learning
techniques many more tips you can
utilize in order to learn faster and for
longer however the main point of this
video other than the fact that you
should learn lots of different things is
that by combining the huge resource and
power of the internet with accelerated
learning techniques and with an end goal
in mind and then applying it to the gig
economy
our new economy we're staying in one job
for a long time isn't so common is an
incredibly powerful and worthwhile
endeavor I'd love to know what other
tips you have let me know in the
comments down below I'd love to know
what books you recommend what YouTube
channels all that let's discuss it
together thanks a ton for watching I
really appreciate it if you enjoyed this
video then please leave a like please
share it around that helps me out
immensely we're really close to 50,000
subscribers now which is awesome so
thanks a ton for that thanks also to
grant who's been doing a fantastic job
with the martial arts content and I've
got some more interesting contributors
hopefully lined up for you soon so stay
tuned there's lots of awesome stuff
coming to the channel very soon and in
the short term I'll be doing my promised
videos on Bruce Lee the myth vs. reality
as well as a real-life Bruce Wayne style
training program so if that sounds good
then subscribe I'll see you next time
thanks a ton for watching and bye for
now